hello there you're watching the press
preview our first look at what's on the
front pages as they arrive
over the next half an hour we'll see
what's making the headlines with the
journalists and author rachel shabby
and the telegraph's leader writer tim
stanley so good evening to both of you
nice to see you both
hello there so let's take a look then
what's making the front pages first and
the observer goes with the growing
backlash over the one percent
pay rise offered to nhs staff
as does the sunday people it's time to
pay up
boris is the headline there the sunday
telegraph writes that boris johnson's
europe advisor lord frost has said the
european union needs to
stop complaining about brexit and make
it work
the chancellor rishi sunak is leading a
global push to get
tech giants to pay more tax according to
the sunday express
the queen won't be watching the duke and
duchess of sussex's interview with oprah
according to the sunday times
splash and that interview also makes the
front of the sunday mirror it says
palace aids could involve the duchess of
cambridge in the investigation into
bullying allegations and it's fair to
say the daily start on sunday has a
strong opinion on that interview which
will air in the uk
on monday night
we will be talking about that issue in
just a moment rachel shabby and tim
stanley here with me but
rachel first of all we're kicking off
with a story that makes it onto a couple
of the front pages of the sundays again
tomorrow
and this is um the reaction to the
government's proposed one percent pay
rise for nhs workers which has prompted
anger amongst unions and the observer
also suggesting
um that the public aren't too keen
either according to a poll is that right
yeah that's right i mean the anger does
seem to be across the board and we've
been hearing
all day from uh nurses and other nhs
staff and as you say
uh union representatives across the
airwaves um
so just talking about how this is you
know
tipped staff over the edge that it's
just being experienced
as a kick in the teeth um one union
representative is saying he's never
he's never seen the public mood like
this uh nurses in so much despair
but as you say the public polling that
the observer is reporting on shows
a majority of all voters think the one
percent
uh pay increase for nhs staff is too low
also a majority of conservative voters
are saying the same thing and 38 35
sorry of the public according to the
observer
are feeling angry about it and you can
see why
the paper is also reporting that the
shadow chancellor annalisa dodds is
saying that in real terms
um this has meant a 300 pound
pay cut for nurses particularly newly
qualified nurses
and that's when you factor in things
like inflation
and also the freezing of the
personal tax allowance which the
chancellor sort of snuck into the budget
last week and which will put 1.6 million
people
into a different tax bracket so all
these things combined
are obviously causing rising anger at
the fact that
nhs staff which as we know have put
themselves
at the front line have made so many
sacrifices for
us uh they've seen their colleagues
tragically lose their lives over the
last year
they're facing extreme stress um
fatigue low morale anxiety
stress burnout the departure rates
nhs staff who say they really want to
leave as a result of the pandemic and as
a result of the
low pay um now going through the roof so
it's a very
desperate situation and you can
completely understand why there's so
much anger about it
well yes and the government has said
haven't they tim that
they're paying what they can afford and
they will point to rishi sunax budget
early in the week which shows that the
parlor state of the nation's finances
but it is politically uncomfortable for
them isn't it to be
offering such a small pay rise to these
workers who right from the very top
right from the prime minister
have garnered so much praise during the
pandemic
the government would also say that there
are multi-year pay deals which will see
nhs workers wages rise there is an
opportunity
i think in may for a review of this so
don't be surprised if there is a change
to the one percent figure
but also don't be surprised if there is
an even sooner change than that
if i was a tory mp right now i would not
be wasting my political capital
defending this
because i suspect there'll be a u-turn
on it very soon because it's so very
unpopular um and because it's it it's
politically
very difficult to sell to people but the
reality is is that
we britain is running out of money it is
running a colossal deficit
it has got difficult spending choices
that it has to make uh the chancellor is
already looking at tax rises so that's
being covered
there's going to be spending cuts will
start to take place in two years time
and because the nhs is such an enormous
employer employs
around 1.3 million people in the uk
even a one percent increase in wages it
is estimated costs around 500 million
pounds to the taxpayer
we pay that we are the people who pay
that
doesn't mean they shouldn't get it and i
can see the arguments for it and i
understand
after a year of as rachel put it very
eloquently all this suffering and pain i
can understand why people feel
that nhs staff should be rewarded but we
pay it
and there are other things to spend
money on too and we haven't got as much
money as we would like to have
and furlough's not being wound down
tomorrow the costs of covered are going
to be
long term this is gonna this is the
first this feels like this is the
the firing shot in what will be a long
battle
over spending priorities for the next
couple of years the budget last week
tried to level with the public try to be
honest about the state of the finances
and put things
on a sure footing but the reality is
that battle has only just beat
has only just begun and this is the
first very
emotionally difficult step in that but
we're going to see
many many more rows like this because
britain simply does
not have the cash okay go on go on then
quickly rachel no i think i think the
trouble with what tim is saying is that
that has been
shown to be nonsense in the year of the
pandemic
so this idea that there is no money is
obviously not true because in a year
when we needed to spend
the state could spend there is a magic
money tree
it's called the bank of england when the
government borrows
it borrows from 92 percent of its
borrowing comes from the bank of england
which is
probably the nicest and friendliest um
you know lender you could ask for and
at the moment rates are zero so it's a
fallacy to say that we don't
we can't spend we can spend
the key phrase there is at the moment
the rates are zero
yes you can print the money yes you can
borrow the money but what do you do you
devalue your currency in the long run
you create the potential for inflation
and at some point of interest rates go
up you suddenly find yourself having to
pay all that stuff off
and we don't have rachel touched on a
very important point here
this government this tory government has
given the impression in the last year
that there is a magic money tree
it has conjured the money out of nowhere
and that's why in the future people are
going to say well if you could pay for
it then
why can't you pay for it now but the
fact is that that money was just
magicked up it's not real money and you
can't go on doing that
the return to normal will mean a return
to the kind of spending we had before
you cannot continue doing what we've
done for the last
year i'm going to move this on because
there's another issue which i suspect
will
garner a lot of conversation not just
amongst youtube but across the country
which is picked up on a number of the
front pages let's try and talk about
this a bit before the break
sunday times first of all uh focusing on
harry and megan's interview with oprah
winfrey tomorrow night
they are saying the queen's not gonna
watch but let's also
show a couple of the other front pages
dealing with this tomorrow the sunday
mirror
they're saying fears kate will be
dragged into meg bully row
and also we've got it on the front of
the sunday express
as well not their main story but they're
that picture story
queen's mind is only on duty and philip
they say
rachel what do you make of the coverage
ahead of this interview
i mean i think that the
i think that the royals and and the
press
the print media really lost the plot
about this
i mean the coverage over the last few
days has been near hysterical
in the level of attacks on um megan
mostly it has to be said and also harry
um and it's really interesting to see
now the sunday times reporting that the
queen won't watch
this program uh which we all will be
watching
uh tomorrow night it's very much become
appointment viewing
i think we have to wait till monday just
i think it's it airs in america doesn't
it on sunday and then we've got to wait
another day in case people are already
sitting there
sorry they're again recorded for us yeah
sunday night um
but yeah this is this is the courts this
is the
um the royal family saying you know this
is trivial and we want to just get back
to normal and we won't indulge in this
circus
but the fact of the matter is that they
have been indulging in the circus
they've been leading the circus
for the last few days they've been
briefing all kinds of nonsense
about meg about megan so it is peculiar
to now see them say actually we're
taking the higher
the higher growth okay i just want a
quick thought from tinx we ought to be
going to a break now but i want to hear
what you think as well too
i actually agree with rachel on the one
hand the palace is saying we're
above this we don't care we're getting
on with business on the other hand there
is briefing against the sussex is going
on
in this country i think the balance of
opinion favors
uh the palace and is sympathetic towards
the queen because people here generally
feel that the sussex is
wolfed off into the sunset in america
it's very different
their sympathy is squarely on the side
of the sussexes i suspect however the
interview itself will be
quite boring because usually when people
say i'm going to tell you my truth
it always turns out to be incredibly
dull
well we'll find out won't we not so long
to wait
okay we're going to take a break right
now plenty more to talk about coming up
including
we've all felt pandemic induced anxiety
now the sunday time says it's causing
ticks in teenage girls we're going to
talk about that
welcome back you're watching the press
preview with me tonight the journalist
and author rachel shabby and the
telegraph leader writer tim
stanley and tim we're turning to the
sunday express next um and they have a
story about
rishi sunak on the back of the budget
suggestions for how he might be able to
raise some cash
this is a goal of um economists across
the world how do you
tax the internet giants because while
they can make massive amounts of profit
excuse me they get massive amounts of
profit in one country they will of
course be physically located elsewhere
so they don't necessarily pay
uh the the usual proportion of tax on
the profit they've made in that
in that third country so the chancellor
is reportedly
going to try to get the major economies
to work
on a new tax system which will allow
them to tax that wealth as one way
of making up for the costs of covid and
lockdown
now that not only would make a certain
amount of fiscal sense but
some people would see it as sweet
justice because of course one group of
companies that have done very well out
of lockdown are the internet giants
thanks to
uh people using the internet for things
like deliveries so
this sort of makes some sense there will
of course be some pushbacks against it
because others will point out that
internet companies invest invest in
places like britain uh precisely because
of the low tax regime
but nonetheless this this feels a bit
like the railroads in the 19th century
like a monopoly whose time has come
and who are finally going to have to
start paying their bills interesting one
to watch
and i'm going to move us on rachel to a
story that you spotted on the front of
the sunday times next
and this is rather troubling headline a
teenage girl suffer explosion of ticks
in lockdown and
i'm sure it'll it'll over time we will
learn some of the the costs of what's
been going on behind closed doors
yeah i think we're only just starting to
see
you know tip of the iceberg in terms of
the sort of anxiety
anxiety disorders and mental health
related
issues that um that people have been
suffering in lockdown particularly
young people uh young people according
to this research
project for the sunday times um report
to mostly feeling um anxiety
pessimistic about the future in a sense
of helplessness
and um this is fueling it is thought
this surge that that um the health
health
workers are seeing in tick disorders so
all kinds
of uh repetitive and involuntary
movement
disorders um including tourette's but
also
just rolling the eyes jerky movements
that sort of thing
again just incredibly sad uh this is
one of the sort of byproducts of the
huge pressure um that we've all been
under but of course uh can hit
young people in a much more extreme way
and
has appeared to have done so with
teenage girls
adolescent girls with these disorders